[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt hatte geht es weiter mit unserer
vum tour ihr durftet entscheiden und die
entschieden für das schlafzimmer
bestimmt weil es der privateste raum
überhaupt ist bei uns im haus also zeige
ich euch heute hier wird gestrichen
haben lacht noch libyens eingerichtet
haben was ich bei der möbel suche
beachtet habe und wie ich habe hier
ziehen wir jetzt gerade eine
trockenbauwand ein damit das zimmer
unterteilt wird was mir nämlich im alten
schlafzimmer nicht gefallen hat war dass
es zum halt voller möbel steht das heißt
im bett und kleiderschrank eine kommode
und noch andere kleine möbelstücke und
jetzt möchten wir so wenig möbel wie
möglich im schlafzimmer stehen haben und
verlagern den kleiderschrank praktisch
hinter die trockenbauwand wenn man das
zimmer dann betritt sieht man nämlich
nur noch das bett und die kommode und
dann wirklich zimmer einfach etwas
gemütlicher für die wand haben wie
rheinmetall konstrukt gebaut und mit
rigips platten verkleidet und roberto
hat er anschließend noch eine stücke
pompei technik angewandt
das zimmer habe ich dann in einem
taubenblau gestrichen weil blau gerade
in schlafräumen kühl ruhig und meditativ
und vor allem sauber wirkt und dadurch
schafft man einfach eine entspannte und
friedvolle atmosphäre
in manchen xxxlutz häusern gibt es war
eine world of box springen da kann man
alle betten mal ausprobieren und sich
wirklich richtig beraten lassen und kann
so das passende bett frist selbst finden
[Musik]
also lustig und so fühlt sich so an mit
einem großen mann sexy so und das ist im
bett wo von unserer freundin die sie
sollte nämlich schon geschwärmt hat die
hat schon bei sich zu hause seit vielen
jahren glauben bockspringen bett habt
ihr vielleicht schon gehört das heißt
nicht morath also darauf springen darf
auch samira auch nicht erlaubt ok
sondern bockspringen bedeutet nur box
von kasten und spring von federn also
feder kasten unten hat man also die
erste schicht das sind die federn mit
drin
obendrüber kommt eine hochwertige
matratze natürlich auch passend
abgestimmt auf die vista xp und
obendrüber der top und ich finde die
betten eigentlich echt richtig cool so
manchmal auch die sondern jeder gehen
zehn jahren und habe als hier einfach
dieser komfort höhe kann sich gleich
hinsetzen ich zumindest passt bei dir
auch oder sich auch bei dir ja und das
ist auch dieter knoll dazu sagen und
wieder kommt aus ich finds echt schön
und es kann mir da in jeder farbe
bestellen
in jeder farbe in diesem dialog dialog
textil leder also kunstleder
wir bekommen ist ein stoff natürlich
noch man sieht in modernen farben also
man kann wirklich den mut freien lauf
lassen
also ich find's schön murat dann kann
man eben gerade mit dem mit der wand
alles so ein bisschen im zimmer so zu
grau und warum diese neues bisher bin
ich cool
jetzt machen wir das bett grau und dann
kann man mit der bettwäsche befahrbaren
weg ins nächste mama den kleiderschrank
von 10 bis 19 uhr könnt ihr hier probe
liegen
jetzt finde ich hier noch die wand deko
an die wand an
und wenn ihr mal keinen meterstab habt
dann könnt ihr trotzdem ganz gut die
löcher in der wand bohren und zwar nehmt
ihr einfach ein bisschen kreppband und
spannt es hier direkt zwischen die zwei
löcher
denn ich muss er den abstand wissen für
die zwei schrauben dann abreißen und
genau mittig markieren
jetzt habt ihr praktisch hier den
abstand zwischen den beiden löchern und
dann nehmt euch einfach mehr wasserwaage
entspanntes direkt hier drauf und damit
kann ich dann im prinzip wenn ich jetzt
nur ein bild habe klappt ganz gut kann
ich hier ans wasser gehen anzeigen und
an bord
ich habe es natürlich drei bilder also
muss ich trotzdem messen würde aber
trotzdem im prinzip so auch
funktionieren
[Musik]
und wenn ihr auch so einen langen ball
habt aber nur seinen kurzen dübel dann
also ihr seht es auch hier der ist
wirklich nur die hälfte
dann könnt ihr so ein bisschen kreppband
und kurz hinterm dübel hier am bohrer
markieren dann weiß ich hier dass ich
einfach nicht zu tief bohren darf das
kein strom mehr
sollte ich live kontakt mehr frauenpower
[Musik]
beim born habe ich immer hier auf stufe
2 und wenn ich schraube rein dreht dann
auf stufe eins dann ist bisschen
langsamer und beim eindrehen habe ich
ein bisserl mehr gefühl
[Musik]
ziemlich schwierig denn das sind so
handgemachte die urteile und die
schrauben und die schraube löcher sind
natürlich auch nicht ganz so perfekt
angebracht also ja ein bisschen
höhenunterschied
ich gucke jetzt einfach gleich das alles
so ziemlich gerade wird die bilder
hängen des bettes bezogen jetzt wird das
schlafzimmer noch fertig dekoriert wir
haben übrigens ein ventilator an der
decke wir haben hier bei uns im haus
eine belüftungsanlage man hört sie auch
ganz leicht die funktioniert auch
wirklich super
denn ich kann in stickigen räumen nicht
schlafen also ich bin immer so ein
fenster auf reise gewesen bei mir war
immer das fenster offen egal ob sommer
oder winter und da aber immer so unseren
ersten streitpunkte hab mir murat den er
sagte immer im winter höher auf die
fenster aufzureißen das verbraucht viel
zu viel energie weil das haus sich
wieder hoch muss also haben wir hier im
kompletten haus jetzt eine
belüftungsanlage und ich habe einfach
immer durch dieses kleine loch hier an
der wand immer frische luft das heißt
unsere schlafzimmerfenster sind
tatsächlich permanent immer zu außer es
ist draußen richtig schön kühl und wir
wollen die wohnung oder das haus
abkühlen ansonsten muss ich morgens
wirklich kein schlafzimmer lüften ich
habe permanent frische luft meine nase
geht nicht so und ich habe keine
kopfschmerzen und was ich hier auch habe
ist hier die sonne
die haben wir schon als deko angebracht
weil ich einfach schön finde wenn man im
schlaf wenn man so eine sonne hängen
habt dann wachst du morgens auf und die
sonne ist schon da ja jetzt wo ich noch
ein paar dicke teile kerzen ich habe ich
noch ein hocker wo ich mal hier rein und
zeigt euch wie ich das schaf nur
dekorieren d'italia hatte ich noch in
der deckung abteilung gefunden und ich
finde ja auch echt schön so aus holz und
die werde ich jetzt einfach noch ein
bisschen aufpimpen damit sie zum
restlichen schlafzimmer passen da habe
ich ja schon diese sonnenhängen dieser
gold also mache ich einfach ein bisschen
der goldene farbe drauf
ich nehme jetzt hier entweder das
veredlung spray oder den goldlack und
ich bin jetzt einfach mal beides aus ich
nehme jetzt erstmal den goldlack und ein
schwamm und streich einfach so ein
bisschen drüber
ich brauche jetzt erst mal die farbe
hier aus jetzt tut sich hier einfach
über die oberfläche drüber sondern nicht
ganz gold werden sondern so ganz leicht
vergoldet sein wenn man mit dem schwamm
so ziemlich oberflächlich bleibt dann
bleibt man wirklich auf der ersten
schicht und trifft hier diese ornamente
wenn man tiefer drückt dann kommt die
ganze fläche groß raus habe ich bleibe
hier auf der oberfläche so kommen die
ordnung interesse heraus
trainer
[Musik]
mit diesem einfachen trick könnt ihr im
handumdrehen eure dekoelemente noch ein
bisschen individualisieren
[Musik]
diese hocker kommt jetzt hier das
fenster aber nicht zum wäsche abladen
also da muss ich mit aussprechen darf
hier keine wäsche abwarten das nicht
wirklich aber nur schöne sitzmöglichkeit
wenn man sich mal umziehen will oder
eben auch einfach was schönes
dekoratives und da kommt jetzt noch ein
schönes tablett drauf mit kerzen lohan
vielleicht ich muss mal gucken dann
gucke ich mir das gesamtbild ab
[Musik]
direkt vor ort
die kommt es hier noch meinen ja
es war nicht gut
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt unser fertiges
schlafzimmer aus und ich finde es auch
ziemlich bequem vor allem das bett ich
muss echt sagen in unserem alten bett in
der wohnung da hatte ich echt sehr oft
fast jeden tag rückenschmerzen weil
wahrscheinlich die matratze nicht so gut
war dass wert an sich nicht so gut und
seitdem wir hier schlafen ist es echt
viel besser geworden im schlafzimmer
haben wir keinen fernseher
denn das ist ja ein raum in dem man zur
ruhe kommt und allgemein haben wir
sowieso nur einen fernseher im ganzen
haus weil wir nicht so viel fernseh
schauen und wenn dann alle zusammen im
erdgeschoss so was kann ich noch zeigen
das sideboard hier haben wir dann
nachträglich noch dazu gestellt einfach
weil wir gemerkt haben
der kleiderschrank hat doch nicht so
ganz ausgereicht und bettwäsche oder
handtücher sind jetzt hier verstaut da
haben sie immer griffbereit gerade hier
zum wett machen immer ganz praktisch und
man hat ja auch immer so ein bisschen
unterlagen die habe ich auch hier drin
so was wie keine ahnung dieser
untersuchungsheft ihren von den kindern
oder mein alter motor passen oder sogar
mein eigenes untersuchungshäftling das
hat meine mama noch aufbewahrt wird
ali hashemi mädchenname stück verliebt
heißt das ja das habe ich ja noch oder
unserer stammbuch
das ist übrigens im stammbuch das habe
ich irgendwann mal getauscht das ist
nämlich 1 was meine freundin entwickelt
hat und design tat die leila und zwar
ist das so ein muslimisches stammbuch
denn oft haben wir also gerade als
muslime oder nichtchristen das problem
da kriegst du ja beim standesamt
wirklich nur diese vorlagen mit der
taufe und mit allem und hier hat man
einfach die muslimische variante also da
fehlt einfach die taufe weil es im islam
nicht gibt oder eben auch die patentante
patenonkel es gibt es bei uns auch nicht
und hier sind einfach alle vorlagen drin
die dann wirklich für eine muslimische
hochzeit gedacht sind
ich habe morgen hier habt ihr dann
einfach auch passende namen eben auch
die vornamen die wir genommen haben geht
zum beispiel sarah mein name gute
anständige und ordentliche
und hier ist samira gesprächspartnerin
aber es heißt auch die prinzessin murat
erwünscht beabsichtigt das was man
wünscht
und deswegen ist es echt ganz schön und
das habe ich dann irgendwann einfach mit
unserem ausgetauschten habe jetzt hier
alles drin oder zum beispiel auch das
muss ich noch fertig machen
wahrscheinlich kennt ihr das ist so ein
kleines schwangerschaft und baby buch
gott hab ich sogar noch das konservieren
und damals dachte ich noch dass ella mit
doppel l geschrieben werden sollte und
dann haben wir sie doch mit eine mail
geschrieben
meine ganzen fertig machen aber ich bin
da echt muss ich sagen bisschen
nachlässig geworden ob kommunikation 3d
bilder
das geht doch schnell
weil man dort offen welches kind aber
naja murat ist so schwer zu erzählen
deswegen ja ich bin da echt wir sind
nachlässig also selbst unser
hochzeitsalbum gibt es nicht und samira
und ella kriegen auch noch eins aber ich
kann nur dazu dazu hat das haben wir
hier so drin oder halt die sachen die
die mädels mir schenken
gut das muss ich vielleicht
wahrscheinlich herausstellen da wusste
ich noch nicht wohin
vielleicht ständig zilien oder sogar da
oben mit rein und ansonsten haben wir
hier oben im kompletten obergeschoss
einfach diesen parkettboden finde ich
richtig schön vor allem wenn man was
drauf läuft das ist dieser kers parkett
um mein papa der wollte immer keine
laminatböden und keine parkettböden weil
er aber auch nicht wusste wie toll
parkett ist und er hatte zu hause immer
korkböden weil die einfach im sommer
schönen kühl sind und im winter aber
warm und parkett ist einfach recht das
beste also wir haben es ja auch drüben
bei meinen eltern weiß auch parkett oder
sind die auch mega begeistert
und wir haben ja einen kompletten haus
und selektion smart home system und
gerade hier im schlafzimmer ist es auch
wirklich von vorteil denn ich habe hier
auf dem nachttisch sondern kleinen
schalter und da kann ich einfach auf
alle funktionen betätigen wie zum
beispiel abends einfach den schlaf modus
aktivieren so dass wirklich die
bewegungsmelder deaktiviert werden und
ich nachts wenn ich auf die toilette
gehen oder wenn die kinder zu uns ins
bett griechen einfach ein kleines licht
haben damit sie sich nicht uns anstoßen
aber dennoch vom großen wichtig gestört
werden unser schlafzimmer hat insgesamt
35 quadratmeter aber weiter unterteilt
wenn wir diese trainer und hier
eingezogen hier vorne nur das bett und
das sideboard und hier hinten dran haben
wir dann unseren kleiderschrank da zeige
ich euch aber in einem eigenen video mal
was ich dafür hacks habe was für tipps
und tricks beim zusammenlegen und hier
dahinter haben wir dann direkt und sah
badezimmer aber das zeige ich euch auch
ein anderes mal ja das war unser
schlafzimmer
also ich hoffe euch gefällt was er
gesehen habt mir gefällt so echt schon
ganz gut wir fühlen uns sehr wohl und
schlaf wie auch ganz werden und kommen
auch wirklich sehr bezogen
und falls ihr noch fragen oder
anregungen haben wünscht das nächste
video schreibt es gerne unten in die
kommentare dann berücksichtige ich darf
auf jeden fall und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß mit den anderen videos und wir
sehen uns wieder beim nächsten mal
ich glaube ja hier ist ein schöner tag
klassiker dazu
und sobald noch was von eller dazu kommt
stelle ich das auch noch doktor
[Musik]